if you want to show you page one of this
morning's Minneapolis star-tribune it
calls the violence that you just saw a
state of agony joining us now is
Minnesota Minnesota Attorney General
keith Ellison he's a former congressman
from the district that includes
Minneapolis attorney general Ellison
thank you for being with us there's so
much to get to but I want to begin with
your reaction to those protests
overnight as well as your reaction to
the president and people who may agree
with him that these people are thugs who
in some cases may deserve to be shot
well calling people thugs and calling on
people to get shot is stems from the
same sort of attitude that resulted in
the death of George Floyd that the tough
guy macho man I'm gonna make you do what
I want you to do attitude is the heart
of the problem and we need the the
president and everybody else who thinks
that you can get to a better place
through threats of violence to stop it I
think your violence begets violence and
Trump's angry words just feed an ugly
cycle that is going on in my beloved
city which I'm so proud of but I'm just
painting for now look here's what I say
to the people who were protesting you
have made your point
do not let people who want to burn or
break things distort the message of
justice for George the fact is he
deserves to have his case heard justice
needs to come forward but we can't with
now the conversation is has shifted to
you know what has happened in the
streets as opposed to what's going to
happen to these officers who so
horrifyingly
you know treated him on the corner of
Chicago and 38 so we need to refocus our
attention on what really matters and we
need to ignore the calls of people like
Donald Trump and we need to really start
to summit our city our great city back
in back in back the way it was and try
to be in a better place so mister 2004
so mr. Attorney General on that subject
getting to a better place and justice
for George Floyd what does justice look
like in your view well look when you are
in the business of prosecution and
investigation prejudging what you're
gonna do before you have facts is not a
good idea because we do have a Sixth
Amendment right to a fair trial I don't
want a defense attorney to get up and
say oh they all were against my client
from the beginning that's not true but
we have all seen the videotape it's
deeply disturbing it looks very very
much like George
Floyd was abused and mistreated and it
looks like that knee on the neck may
well have caused his death
that is those facts are in front of our
eyes in the whole world at this point I
think we need to move forward now in the
expeditious but thorough way to complete
whatever investigation is needed and to
bring charges if warranted now of course
I have my own opinion about whether
those charges are warranted I clearly do
but I'm not going to start announcing
those things in order to prejudice an
investigation and hand the other side a
defense so I'm going to just say we're
going to follow the evidence and I think
this case needs to be moving forward in
the most expeditious manner what the you
know the protesters are calling for
charges if charges are warranted
there is no reason that we should stop
and and halt and and and not move
forward with that so those are my views
on this time mr. Ellison mr. Ellison yes
I think everybody wants to make sure
that justice is done here and I think
part of the problem is if it was a
normal citizen who was seen on tape
doing what this police officer was doing
we keep hearing about you can arrest
people on probable cause can you help us
all understand why this police officer
and then the video from the other side
mr. Ellison where you see two other
officers
holding mr. Floyd down while he's while
he's begging and pleading for his life
why haven't these men been arrested and
the investigation continued it happens
all of the time when you see somebody
that looks like they committed a crime
and we're all watching that's what's
that's why there's so much pain and
there's so much anger in your city today
you have to help us understand ma'am I'm
very well aware of why there's pain and
anger in my city I lived here I live my
whole adult life here my raised my four
kids here I've represented this district
in Congress I know about my city okay
but I will tell you that it is true that
probable cause can support a criminal
complaint and the jurisdiction that has
primary responsibility for charging has
decided up until this moment not to do
so the Minnesota Attorney General's
Office is not legally authorized to
charge unless it until the case is
referred to us at which time we will
handle the case according to law in an
expeditious and thorough manner in
accordance with justice that's what we
will do but if you're misunderstanding
you're misunderstanding my question
you're misunderstanding my question I'm
not asking about the attorney general's
office I'm asking as someone who
understands the law why these police
officers haven't been charged I'm not
saying I'm not trying to tell you why I
state in anger in your city I know you
love the city yes please I answer yes
please may I answer please the answer is
the authority for making the charge
decision has not done so that is the
answer do they have good reasons I
assume so that's the answer all right
Attorney General Keith Ellison we'll
have to leave it there of course there's
more to discuss thank you for your time